we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p i will play a
voicemail for you right now they uh
David in Louis is next in Connecticut
call again uh watching your episode from
yesterday where you Louis talking about
Trump University and Trump claiming all
this tremendous hostility imposed upon
him by the judge are there any samples
are examples cited about this alleged
yeah hostility there or not I mean it
did it it's all conjecture it's all even
Paul Ryan now has said that it's racist
conjecture they're absolutely no
examples whatsoever of Judge curial
being a even at all hostile to donald
trump specifically by virtue of of being
supposedly Mexican mean Indiana born guy
on the bonus show today lewis is going
to tell us about what he's describing is
the most insane scam telephone call of
all time he has been refusing to tell me
about it because he wants to have my
honest first reaction on the bonus show
we will talk about turkey sinking a
plane to boost tourism and also uh a
rapists dad says that six months is too
long of a jail sentence for just 20
minutes of what he describes as action
sign up for the bonus show and all
membership options and features at david
pakman.com slash membership and of
course i have 13 of those half-price
memberships available if you want one of
them email me david at david pakman.com